a study that just came out found that
it's better this is serious better to be
born dumb and have rich parents than it
is to be born smart and have poor
parents they find out yeah yes it was an
eight year study of the Trump children
apparently Eric just put it over the top
we're done we got it would you guess
that to be true better to have was it be
porn I can't even remember eight no dad
was rich parents yes and then smart with
poor exactly I yeah probably yeah yeah
money does grease the gears yeah
the whole system's rigged let's get out
of here right one person was with me on
that there was one guy willing to follow
me in the parking lot to accomplish
nothing thank you
earlier today speaking the Trump's
earlier today President Trump called in
to a show on CNBC to defend his stance
on tariffs
he called in yeah then two minutes later
Trump called again and won free tickets
to see maroon 5
a passenger with that was caught vaping
on a flight has been banned for life
from Spirit Airlines yeah
the man said my plan worked perfectly
how do you mind aping i was trying to
mine vaping
I've never vaped and I don't know how I
did this why do you ask me oh come on
I've seen you hot boxing in your car on
the way on